my question is this as a military man
what do you do if you cannot reconcile
the orders that you're asked to do I
know that in your book you talk about
believe the mission and how do how you
must ask questions until you believe
what happens if after all the questions
and all the expect as explanations you
don't agree or believe what if the
policy the politics asked of you
something you're not congruent with how
do you as a military man respond to
you're in congruence with the mission so
this is a great question and I'm and you
know it's kind of ties in with what we
just read with the book review of
machete season how people were just
doing if some of them didn't believe in
what they're doing they did it anyways
wrong answer then he resulted in the
death of the one guy you know you talk
about that's in the book but you know so
first of all as you as you stated in the
question itself if you don't agree with
some mission that you've been given then
you have to ask the question why in the
book extreme ownership we talk about
that the primary example is we talk
about is working with Iraqi soldiers and
how that's very challenging and very
difficult and very dangerous and the
story that we tell in the book is that I
said to myself okay why are they having
us work with these Iraqi soldiers my
guys are going to be at risk etc etc and
eventually I realized why we needed to
do this was because if we didn't get the
Iraqi soldiers to a point where they
could handle the security in Iraq then
who was gonna do it the answer was us so
I understood why now
I actually didn't have to ask anybody
why I figured that out I asked myself
why and so I was able to come to it come
to that conclusion but when you are part
of something whether it's in business or
it's in war the the goal the ultimate
goal it has to be aligned in it so for
example where in Iraq we're supposed to
use Iraqi soldiers okay
do you think that the generals wanted
our men to be killed because the
higher-risk know they wanted to win the
war they want to keep our guys safe so
that's what I wanted to we want to win
the war we want to keep her guys safe
so that's aligned so anything that
they're telling me to do it must be at
some point in the distance aligned with
the same goal that I have and it's the
same thing with a business do you think
a boss of a business doesn't want to be
profitable or doesn't want to be ethical
no somewhere in the future they want to
be profitable they want to be F ethical
and somewhere
your mission is gonna align with that if
you don't if those don't align at some
point then you got a real serious issue
on your hands right because maybe you're
being told to do something that you just
don't believe in and you ask for you
know like I said you got to ask those
questions all the way up and if you do
ask those questions all the way up and
you still find ok I don't believe in
this mission now you got a way out the
consequences mmm because for instance if
there's an order that comes and for
whatever reason you don't believe in it
you've asked the questions and you still
don't believe that it's the right thing
to do but what if it's something that's
like pretty inconsequential right
something that's no big deal and you say
no to it like I'm not gonna do this you
decide to make your stand okay well now
you're you're first of all you're not
supporting the chain of command anymore
and if you're not supporting your chain
of command anymore how can you support
the guys that work for you hmm
because now you might get removed and if
you get removed from the situation now
who's gonna go execute it who's gonna go
do this thing that you thought was wrong
now you're gonna give it to somebody
that might execute it in a harsher way
in a worse way or you lose control of it
you've lost your influence you used up
some of your political capital
you've impaired your reputation by
saying no I'm not gonna do that because
I don't believe in it Oh what was it
and by saying no what did you accomplish
because now you have no control over
anymore your your you can't change it
you can't affect it anymore
so let me ask you this this is an
example this will make it very clear
what I'm trying to say cuz I don't think
I'm being very clear right now if you're
playing a game right you're playing a
football game or a basketball game and
the ref makes a bad call mm-hmm okay so
you say the ref made a bad call I don't
agree with this call I quit and walking
off the court now does that make sense
I mean how bad of a call was it how did
it affect the game and and furthermore
once you walk off the court what good
are you
mmm can you can you do better can use
try and bring back the score can you try
and show the ref that yes you are
playing fair look I'm a good guy I'm
keeping my head I'm keeping my cool no
you've thrown that all away you've
thrown that all the way and so what good
is that it's the same thing and not
necessarily the ref because that's sort
of outside your chain of command but
what if your own coach what if your
coach pulls you out of a game hmm or a
coach calls a play to you for you to run
a play that you didn't believe in so
you're gonna say you know what I don't
believe in that play I'm walking off the
field that's an exact correlation to
this idea right this military order
comes down that I don't believe in oh I
don't believe in it so now I'm gonna
walk away so that is is problematic
because you've you've given up you've
surrendered your right to affect the
situation and that's that's not good and
in the military there's all kinds of
little you know policy nuances that we
might not believe in a hundred percent
know things there might be little things
that you don't wanna hear I don't I
don't see I don't think that's the best
way to do it I think there's a better
way to do it but if you walk away from
it now you can no longer affect it and
that is bad so much generally speaking
for most of these things you I I doubt I
dealt with in the military all the time
don't with it all the time and you know
what
generally speaking you stay in the game
so that you can still have an effect and
can still have influence now that being
said there can be orders that are
unlawful or unethical that can't happen
right if you are in a bad situation
you're working for a bad commander
you're working for someone that's
unethical or whatever the case may be it
may be their orders or plans that are
tactically unsound to the point that
you're afraid people are gonna die hmm
and in those situations you know as we
were going back to Napoleon's Maxim
again if you execute something that you
knew was wrong you're culpable so then
it is the time when you stand up and say
you know what I'm not doing this you
want to send me to Leavenworth you want
to demote me demote me do it but I do
not believe in this and here's why so
that is a time where you may have to say
after you weigh out the situation how
bad is it something that's unethical
unconstitutional and you think you're
gonna have a bigger impact by protesting
it by possibly jeopardizing your career
or possibly going to going to
Leavenworth if you're in the military
getting court-martialed all those things
could happen if you think that it's so
important and that you will have a
better effect on it by making this
protest is that's what you're doing
you're now making a protest hmm then
okay maybe that makes sense so you got
like them the mail I massacre in Vietnam
were horrible situation happens and if
you were a soldier that was there and
said you know what I'm not doing this
stop and maybe maybe you do rest getting
court-martialed maybe you risk getting
killed
hmm but that's a situation where maybe
you do it or maybe it's some
mistreatment of civilians or something
but again even with mistreatment of
civilians the US military is not going
to order the mistreatment of civilians
it's not going to happen so if it is
happening it's coming from a rogue
commander that you're gonna be able to
destroy when you bring this situation to
the to the authorities or to the higher
chain to come in
so again you know if you're getting
wrapped up in some small nuanced thing
yeah a mentions the poet the political
like if you're not politically congruent
with I don't know if you meant that's
but yeah and again when you're in the
military you're you're not there to
[Music]
worry about the politics of it you know
you're there to carry out the politics
you're there to carry out the policy now
if there's a pollen if the policy is
egregious right right if it's egregious
and you think you will do better to to
make a protest and end up in jail and
you know be on CNN and Fox News and
saying hey this is why I'm in jail
because I didn't agree with what we were
doing if it's something that the rest of
the nation is gonna look at and say yeah
this guy was right of course but if
you're doing it because it's something
that is in comparison that is something
relatively small then you're probably
you're probably doing worse to help the
situation you're probably doing less
good by walking away getting off the
field and letting letting the the the
situation transpire without your
presence hmm I want to be there you know
you know I want to be there if I if my
guys were getting tasked with a mission
that I thought was a little bit sketchy
I want to be there yeah I want to be
there not hey I protest so I'm not gonna
go mmm not a good call so yeah and again
I'm not saying that you don't stand by
your principles but I'm saying is
especially this guy that's in the
military your principles should be for
the most part in line this is America
and if you're if you're if you're being
told to do something that's that's
unamerican
then yeah stand by your principles but
most if it's something that's small and
it's something that you just might not
agree with a hundred percent that
doesn't mean you're an unprincipled
person it means that you are winning
losing the battle but you're gonna win
the war yeah yeah like that way weigh it
out yeah everyone's not like way that
bothers me I'm just being on the
on that side of things